electric car maker tesla is set to open
his first european factory in the coming
weeks the company company has thrown a
party to unveil its new plant just
outside berlin but it's not without
controversy environmental concerns mean
its construction has not yet been given
final approval but that hasn't deterred
tesla founder elon musk
nobody could accuse elon musk of being
short on ambition or showmanship for
that matter and his plans for the new
tesla factory just outside berlin are
characteristically big
we're expecting to
have on the order of 12 000 jobs maybe
more um in fact i'm a little worried we
won't be able to hire enough people so
we really kind of need a great talent to
come here from all around europe
a fair ground atmosphere prevailed in
the factory forecourt drawing in curious
visitors and musk fans from berlin and
further afield some had queued since
early in the morning to get a sneak peek
behind the scenes
temperatures close to freezing couldn't
dampen their enthusiasm
emil and erno were among the thousands
who made the pilgrimage
excited because i uh it's the first time
since couple of months i wasn't here and
last time i was here it was just a clear
field
without
the
some trees
and now the factory is here
the factory aims to deliver up to half a
million electric cars a year to the
european market musk says the first cars
should roll off the assembly line in
just two months time
but for many tesla is more than just a
car maker it's a complete concept for a
high-tech green future
we are part of the the honors club the
tesla owners club program so there's a
huge following huge number of these
people that actually bought the cars but
they actually bought into more than the
cars division of the company itself
despite the hype the project has
encountered stiff opposition the plant
is nearly finished but tesla was never
officially granted a construction permit
some are angry that the factory lies in
a protected water catchment german
authorities are still examining
objections
when the photon is owned
our demand that the factory be
dismantled has not changed it sits in
the middle of a water protection area a
huge breach of law and a danger to the
main water source for 70 000 people
elon musk is not concerned about the
criticism
in halting german he thanked his adoring
fans and urged them to join the party
visionary pioneer savvy businessman or
just another eccentric billionaire
elon musk has polarized the world with
his unorthodox style and ambitious
ventures the new tesla factory outside
berlin is no exception